what is a work
week Americans spend more time in the
office than their counterparts in other
Western Nations but that doesn't always
translate into improved productivity in
fact there's very little linking
productivity to time spent at work or
indeed wages and according to some
social scientists a shorter Work Week
could make people more productive
unionized workers in France tend to
agree while evidence globally suggests
that reduced working hours can in turn
reduce unemployment
[Music]
but in the United States the newly
minted Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell says he wants to increase the
official work week from 30 to 40 hours a
week as part of a peacemeal republican
roll back of President Obama's
Affordable Care Act Right Now companies
with 50 or more workers must provide
Insurance options to employees who work
a 30-hour week or face a fee as a
penalty but Republicans say changing
what constitutes a work week will
provide employers more flexibility to
set workers hours and provide benefits
on their own terms
but according to the Obama
Administration tinkering with that
30-hour work week will chip away at the
employer mandate that made their healthc
care plan feasible in the first place as
with much of the opposition to the
Affordable Care Act ultimately what
constitutes a work week may be decided
by the courts